IT WASN'T NECESSARY FOR MY GOAL,
WHICH WAS TO ALERT HIM THAT WE
HAD THIS INFORMATION.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION AS
FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY, SEAN SPICER.
HE WAS IN A MEETING WHEN COMEY
BRIEFED ON PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT, FOX NEWS NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST, SEBASTIAN
GORKA.
YOU DON'T SEE AT THE SAME WAY,
YOU DON'T RECALL AT THE SAME
WAY?
>> I THINK THE ACCOUNT THAT
DIRECTOR COMEY HAS IN HIS BOOK
IS AT BEST MISLEADING.
LET ME LAID OUT FOR YOU.
THEY WERE ABOUT TO ISSUE A
REPORT ON THEIR FINDINGS OF
RUSSIAN INVOLVEMENT IN THE
ELECTION AND THEY WANTED US TO
BE AWARE OF WHAT THAT REPORT WAS
GOING TO BE.
WE SAT DOWN, HOW DOES THAT
REPORT GIVEN TO US, AT WHICH
TIME, THERE WAS A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS ASKED BY REINCE
PRIEBUS, GENERAL FLYNN, TOM
BROSSARD, AND VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE.
AFTER THE DISCUSSION ENDED, AND
AGAIN, A KEY POINT AND THAT IS
THAT THERE WAS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BACK AND FORTH, WHICH
DIRECTOR COMEY SUGGEST DID NOT
OCCUR.
I JUST NAMED FOUR OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT DEFINITELY ASK
QUESTIONS.
AT THAT POINT, DIRECTOR COMEY
SAID TO THE PRESIDENT ALONE, ACU
PRIVATELY IN THEIR BACK OF THE
ROOM?
THE REST OF US GOT UP AND WENT
OUTSIDE.
AT THAT TIME, AS YOU MAY RECALL,
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
DISTRUST OF MONKS THE POLITICAL
APPOINTEES, SO WE RAN BY THE
STATEMENT THAT WE WILL ISSUE TO
MAKE SURE THERE WAS     DON'T LK
MAKE SURE THERE WAS     DON'T LE
MAKE SURE THERE WAS     DON'T LI
MAKE SURE THERE WAS     DON'T LT
WAS IN ACCORD WITH THE
CLASSIFIED NATURE OF THE
BRIEFING, AND THEY WOULDN'T
DIFFER WITH THE MEETING WE JUST
HAD.
COMEY GOES ON TO TALK ABOUT HOW
IT BECAME A P.R. SESSION.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WENT ON.
FURTHER, AS COMEY HIMSELF SAYS
IN HIS REPORTING HERE, HE
VERBALLY BRIEFED THE
PRESIDENT ON SOME OF THE
SALACIOUS AND UNPROVEN
ALLEGATIONS.
CNN WENT ON TO REPORT FALSELY
THAT HE HAD BEEN GIVEN A TWO
PAGE REPORT.
THAT REPORT WASN'T ACTUALLY EVEN
DONE AT THE TIME THAT WE WERE
BRIEFED.
SO BOTH DIRECTOR COMEY'S ACCOUNT
IS MISLEADING AND CNN IS
REPORTING IS FALSE.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO
DR. GORKA.
SO, THE BIG ISSUE FOR THE MEDIA,
FOR OVER A YEAR, HAS BEEN, OH,
RUSSIAN INFLUENCE IN THE
ELECTION.
AND JAMES COMEY KNEW BEFORE THE
ELECTION HILLARY PAID A FOREIGN
NATIONAL, CHRISTOPHER'S DEAL,
THROUGH FUSION GPS, AND THEY
PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES TO
MANIPULATE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THEN THEY USED IT TO GET A
FISA WARRANT.
AND THEN THEY EXONERATED HILLARY
AFTER PETER STRZOK INTERVIEWED
HER AND THEY BROUGHT THE
EXONERATION MONTHS EARLIER.
AND I AM TRYING TO THINK, YOU
CAN'T MAKE THIS IRONING UP WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
>> IT'S NOT JUST IRONIC.
YOU LOOK AT THE LAST 16 MONTHS,
WHAT DO WE NOW?
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS CAMPAIGN.
BUT WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN THAT
JAMES COMEY IS A LIAR.
WE KNOW THAT JAMES COMEY LEAKS
TO THE MEDIA.
WE KNOW THE FACT THAT HE TRIES
TO GET HIS FRIEND,
ROBERT MUELLER, TO BECOME A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATING
THE PRESIDENT, WHO HE DIDN'T
WANT TO AND MAKE THE ELECTION,
HIS WIFE DIDN'T WANT TRUMP TO
WIN, NOR DID COMEY, THESE ARE
THE FACTS OF THE CASE.
HE HAS DONE MORE SINGLE-HANDEDLY
TO DAMAGE THE FBI THEN J. EDGAR
HOOVER HAS DONE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FACT THAT IN
HIS INTERVIEW YESTERDAY, HE HAS
PROPAGATING THE NARRATIVE OF THE
PRESIDENT POTENTIALLY BEING A
PAWN OF THE RUSSIANS, WHAT IS HE
DOING?
WITH ZERO EVIDENCE, HE IS
ASSISTING IN A RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION OPERATION.
THAT IS WHAT JAMES COMEY IS
DOING.
>> Sean: HE PRESENTED THAT
PHONY INFORMATION TO A COURT TO
SPY ON AN AMERICAN, SEAN.
>> LOOK, IT IS NOT JUST
MISLEADING.
WHAT HE IS SAYING NOW IS IS
FRANKLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
TO GO OUT AND PROFESS LOYALTY
AND CONCERN FOR THESE
INSTITUTIONS AND THEN OPENLY
SPECULATE WITH NO EVIDENCE IS
HIGHLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
HE'S FREE TO DO IT, IT'S A FREE
COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T GO AROUND AND TALK
ABOUT THE LOYALTY THAT YOU HAVE
TO THE INSTITUTIONS TO THIS
COUNTRY AND OPENLY SPECULATE
ABOUT THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND
NOT WONDER, AND NOT HAVE THE
OPPOSITE EFFECT.
THERE IS A REASON I THINK THAT
HIS BOOK, ACCOUNT, AND
APPEARANCE ARE GETTING PANNED.
HE HAS -- IT'S BECOME BROUGHT
HIM, HIS IMAGE, HIS ATTEMPTS TO
SELL BOOKS AND OUT THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: LAST ROAD, DR. GORKA.
>> I WILL JUST TELL YOU WHAT I
RECEIVED RECENTLY, A TEXT FROM
AN FBI AGENT, A SENIOR ONE.
THIS PERSON TOLD ME FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HER LIFE, SHE IS
ASHAMED TO WORK FOR THE FBI.
AND THAT, SHE SAID, IS THANKS TO
JAMES COMEY.
THAT IS WHAT HE HAS DONE, AND
THE NAME OF HIS EGO AND HIS
BOOK.
>> Sean: WE GOT TO REMEMBER IT